there are some things we can do and
they're baked into the system right here
in the United States because we have a
beautiful system founded on the right
ideals we really do we've got things
like the Constitution and the Bill of
Rights and the Declaration of
Independence and The Federalist Papers
all of these documents written by people
who were far better than any of the
people in our public sphere today with
with maybe a couple exceptions and they
gave us this they gave us this blessing
of freedom and we can restore it we
really can restore it but we're gonna
have to put in the work uh Jordan
Peterson was on Russell Brand's podcast
a couple days ago and they were talking
about this idea between individual
rights authoritarian governments and why
governments when fauci earlier he
doesn't know why China would do
something like this but there is a
reason and Jordan explains it quite well
generally speaking Center left liberal
democracies uh using this stuff
nefariously I don't think they care
about the feelings of trans people I
don't think they care I I don't think so
either I care I care and I care about
white Working Class People yeah black
Working Class People brown people from
across the all-class Spectra and what I
feel like is that in order to not engulf
ourselves in a sort of a semantic pyre
we all refocus our attention on the real
giants the oligarchs the tyrants whether
they're buratic or personal that are
using the are narcissistically hoovering
up the power while we're [ __ ] around
with like well this is us this is also
partly the dangerous about the danger of
elevating compassion to the ultimate
virtue because you will you also enable
the narcissists of compassion to Garner
power to themselves by claiming a
compassion they don't have if you
destabilize the identity of local
individuals so they're confused and
aimless it's a hell of a lot easier to
Hoover up all the power
you need slaves to be a tyrant and maybe
I'm more concerned about individuals on
the slave level and you're more
concerned with delineating the nature of
the Tyranny and that's perfectly fine
but I think they're the same problem
do you see what we did here on the
Reuben report program today do you see
how we tied this thing together we
started about a half hour ago talking
about Justin Trudeau and the trans
people or the the drag people I assume
well probably one or two of them are
trans as well but he comes in there just
intro who locked these people down who
ruined Canada's economy who shredded
their founding documents but he comes in
and he sounds nice and he's shimmying
and all those things and then they look
at him despite everything he did to them
and he's oh my God he loves us he loves
us he just loves us so much and then
they become atomized they're not even
real individuals anymore they're just oh
you're the trans people you're the drag
people you behave like this this is how
you should behave and you will not be an
individual so I want to Now read you
Jordan's quote right there that he just
said at the end and you'll see how this
thing all got linked together to why
fauci doesn't know why they would have
lockdowns
and all the rest of it this is Jordan's
quote if you destabilize the identity of
local individuals so they're confused
and aimless it's a hell of a lot easier
to Hoover up all the power you need
slaves to be a tyrant so do you see why
they would want you constantly focused
on gender and sexuality and race and all
of these things that actually don't
matter that much but they make you feel
like those are the most important things
about you and once you think that your
gender and your sexuality are the most
important things in your skin color the
real piece of you the piece of you that
is the thinking you that is within this
skin
with the gender and the genitals and all
the stuff that part will be completely
gone and then they will be able to lock
you down like they're doing in China and
with a zero coveted policy and then our
nonsensical bureaucrats
like Anthony fauci who deserve no power
over anybody and can't figure out why
China would do a thing like that well if
you if you had a belief in yourself if
you had a belief in autonomy and
individuality you would not be giving
power over to them